déviation c'est le mot du jour pour les
automobilistes versailles et la cité
royale accueille le sommet européen au
château de versailles un dispositif de
grande ampleur avec plus de 500
policiers gendarmes et crs mobilisés le
dispositif
décidé et mis en place par un contrôle
de zones de plusieurs zones périmétrique
autour du château est en place donc une
zone complètement étanche dans le
château et des zones à accès est réservé
un peu plus loin autour du château ainsi
que le dispositif de circulation qui
permettra d'accueillir l'ensemble des
délégations participant au sommet pour
les versailles est difficile parfois de
s'y retrouver certains ont eu des
difficultés de circulation le petit
périple aujourd'hui c'est que on
attendait le bus pour aller de la gare
rive droite à la
à la gare rive gauche et du coup on a
attendu plus un quart d'heure on est
montés dans le bus et l'arrêt suivant
c'était le terminus est bien donc on est
obligé de faire toute la route à pied
avec un petit garçon qu'à trois ans
c'est pas facile j'ai pris le bus donc à
montigny qui avait donc un grand crochet
qui a donc qui n'est pas du tout passé
par les arts est donc prévu et qui a
fait presque indirects enfin jusqu'à la
gare il gauche voilà donc je vais
m'adapter et puis j'aime pas les vins
versailles et tant pis je ferais château
un autre jour je dois aller faire une
visite la clinique des franciscaines il
fallait que je me déplace du boulevard
de la reine franciscaine c'est dire
exactement le poser voilà non mais ça va
ils sont pas on est habitué c'est pas le
premier le premier sommet les points
d'accès au périmètre sont nombreux cela
concerne entre autres l'entrée de la
ville sur la rd 10 depuis saint cyr
l'école les rues de satory et de
l'orangerie ainsi que la venue de saint
cloud et la rue carnot les versaillais
avait été prévenue par flyers dans les
boîtes aux lettres finalement la
circulation pour les piétons est plus
simple que pour celle des automobilistes
pour le blocage porte si terrible que ça
parce que pour finir on a été bien
prévenu ça a été bien organisé depuis
ses romans que le tour du château qui
est pris en reste de la ville est
accessible donc aucun problème
particulier ça se fait très bien oui
effectivement ça va a été prévenu on
avait reçu des courriels
de la mairie de versailles donc j'avais
anticipé les choses en me garant dans
une rue qui n'étaient pas bloqués donc
voilà donc pour moi c'est pas très
contraignant finalement côté commerçants
dans la zone rouge interdite aux piétons
et voitures ce restaurant a décidé de
resté ouvert malgré tout on pense qu'on
va travailler avec le chauffeur les
garde corps c'est normal ça soit fermé
pour la sécurité des gens dans la zone
orange beaucoup de commerces sont
ouverts c'est le cas des potences angela
alors ça c'est la mairie qui a déposé
dans les boîtes aux lettres de
versailles avec toutes les indications
des zones rouges et oranges donc nous on
fait partie de la zone orange donc on
savait qu'on pouvait pas stationner
qu'on peut pas mettre les poubelles
dehors et qu'on peut pas faire beaucoup
de choses donc on ouvre si on en a envie
moi c'est ma première fois donc comme je
ne savais pas si j'allais travailler ou
pas eh ben j'ai ouvert j'ai pas fait
plus j'ai pas fait moins que d'habitude
les clients sont au rendez vous autre
information la gare de versailles
château rive gauche est fermée jusqu'à
vendredi 11 mars 18h fin du dispositif
entier également vendredi soir une
cellule d'information du public avec une
ligne téléphonique dédiée est aussi
ouverte